[موسيقى]
يفتك بمن يقف في طريقه لا يهاب القروش ولا
الحيتان العملاقه حتى البشر لم يسلموا من
سلوكه العدائي تجاه قواربهم وكانه يريد
الانتقام لسبب ما وحان وقت الثار من
الجميع انه حوت الاوركا سفاح البحار
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
تعيش حيتان الاوركا في جميع المحيطات
وتفضل الاماكن البارده تعد من اشرس
الكائنات الحيه حتى ان العلماء لقبوها
بذئاب البحار ياكل ويقتل ولا ياكله احد
لذا تراس الهرم الغذائي البحري واصبح ملك
البحار بامتياز تلك الحيتان فائقه الذكاء
تستخدم الحيله للفتك بفرائسها وكثيرا ما
تهاجم بمجموعات غير ابهه بقوه الفريسه او
حجمها تتبع تكتيكات مختلفه كاارهاق
الفريسه الى ان تستسلم او حصارها بحيث لا
تستطيع الهرب عام 2023 زوج من حيتان
الاوركا تسبب وحدهما بقتل 17 سمكه قرش
خلال ساعتين فقط قباله سواحل جنوب افريقيا
في مجزره بحريه مرعبه القرش المفترس تحول
الى فريسه امام شراسه ودهاء الاركا حتى
الحجم الهائل لا يردع هذه المخلوقات ففي
مياه ولايه كاليفورنيا الامريكيه عام 2023
هاجم 30 حوتا من الاوركا حيتانا رماديه
عملاقه لكن لحسن حظها كتبت لها النجاه بعد
ان تمكنت من الهرب جراه الاوركا وصلت
لمهاجمه عملاق البحار واضخم حيوان على وجه
الارض انه الحوت الازرق معركه تبدو محسومه
نظريا لكن للاركى حسابات اخرى هجوم جماعي
في مارس عام 2019 اربك حسابات حوت ازرق
واوقعه فريسه لهم قتلته عضا وخنقا ثم
التهمته في ظاهره نادره الحدوث ومشهد اقرب
الى الخيال
عمليات الهجوم بدت وحشيه جدا حيث قفزت
الاوركا على راس الحوت الازرق وسحبته الى
اعماق الماء والتهمت جزءا من لسانه وهو حي
ايقاف الحوت الازرق اشبه بايقاف قطار بسبب
ضخامه حجمه وسرعته لذا نفذت الاوركا هجمات
سريعه تستهدف الزعانف والراس وتبتعد عن
الذيل لانه قوي جدا
عدائيه هذا الحيوان تجاوزت عالم البحار
والخطر وصل الى البشر حوادث عده ازدادت
مؤخرا لهجوم الاوركا على السفن والقوارب
منذ فتره اغرقت حيتان الارقى قاربا قباله
الساحل الليبيري لاوروبا سته حيتان بدات
بالهجوم بشكل ممنهج ربان القارب تحدث عن
ان الحوت الام بدت وكانها تعلم صغيرها
كيفيه الهجوم على المنكر فيما قال الخبراء
ان تلك الهجمات ليست وليده الصدفه كان
هناك صغيران من حوت الاوركا وواحد اكبر
منهما بدا صغيران في هز الضفه من الخلف
فيما كان الحوت الكبير يصدم جانب السفينه
مرارا وتكرارا بكامل قوته لقد تعجبت عندما
رايت ان الاوركا الصغيرين يقلدان الاكبر
حجما لكن ما السر وراء شراسه حيتان
الاوركا تجاه البشر بعض التفسيرات تفيد
بان حيتان الاوركا تعرضت للتعذيب سابقا
عبر هجمات النفاذاتها القوات الجويه
الامريكيه على هذه الحيتان بسبب شراستها
ضد السكان والصيادين ما كون لديها دوافع
ثاريه من بني البشر لكن ذلك ليس له سند
علمي مؤكد دراسه علميه نشرت في احدى
المجلات اشارت الى ان حيتان الاوركاك
تهاجم القوارب على وجه الخصوص ولا تقصد
بذلك اذيه البشر وبصرف النظر عن دوافعه
يبقى حوت الاوركا خطرا محدقا بالجميع تحت
الماء وعلى سطحه واحد اشرس وادهى
الحيوانات المعروفه في العالم